there was a revelation in the book that
I found interesting because you were
such a thoughtful person I don't think
your mind ever shuts
off you don't believe in therapy you
don't believe in self in analysis I'm
very cautious about it because it hasn't
done no good to No
One
um I can I think it's one of the
Monumental mistakes of the 20th century
among many others uh the the big uh
social Utopias
communism fascism have led to incredible
disasters over population of our planet
and you just name it
destruction of what uh what what nature
is all all of that started really in the
20th century and one of the things that
uh one of the great mistakes of the 20th
Century's psychoanalysis of course it
started some decades earlier but it
really blossomed in the 20th century and
uh I I do believe that the 20th century
in its entirety was a
mistake and going back to um
psychoanalysis I can give you a parable
when you move into a new home and you
illuminate this home to its very last
recesses and Corners with neon lights
everything is
illuminated this house becomes
uninhabitable and human beings uh
illuminated to the
darkest um corners of their soul become
uninhabitable I say it in quotes now and
um you should be careful what you do of
course there are clinical clinical cases
and you you better do it but um this
Mass phenomenon
yeah to think that everything uh in your
inner balance and in your soul and in
your uh emotionality and so will be
solved by psychoanalysis I do not think
it is a a good approach I it's funny
because I think it's it's a
byproduct of this Obsession and you live
in Los Angeles so you see this now in
the 21st century in Los Angeles there's
just this obsession with I want to eat
all the perfect Foods
I want to make sure that I get all the
perfect treatments uh I want to achieve
this perfect state of balance Y Yoga
class is for five years old five year
olds well they Bend so easily yeah yeah
but but but I'm the great defender of
Los Angeles everybody Chuckles and and
says I love Los Angeles too you think
yeah the glitz and glamour of Los
Angeles but everything in the that in
the last half C country um somehow set
the pace in the thinking and the trends
of the world without I mean being
completely trendy originated here the
internet was born here the internet and
I've seen the place where the first
Contact was made uh with routers in
service uh reusable Rockets are being
built in in the perimeters of the city
itself I mean a southern outskirt but
Southern part of it
um all the great painters are here I
think the art scene here is the art
scene they are not in New York anymore
that was early 50s or so uh now they are
here the writers the
mathematicians uh also the of course the
stupidi crazy sects inline no inline
skating is fine but
uh you're listening to runor herzog's
list of what's in and what's out what's
hot and what's cold I actually I'm very
much beloved by skateboarders oh good
there's a community of skateboarders to
have them on your side yeah yes and
they're on my side and I'm on theirs
because the futility and the insistence
try it again try it again try it again
you will do this jump uh up onto the ra
uh onto the railing of no don't do that
no I I'm too old for that and and I've
done ski jumping and ski flying and
almost almost died in doing that but
anyway way you you do you do the wild
stuff when you're young but uh the the
the crazy things also come from here um
originated here and they they have a
worldwide
repercussions uh it it happens and uh
there's no other city like does it
happen in in Chicago or in London or in
Florence OR in Mumbai or in Buenos Iris
no it's Los Angeles it's wonderful to
live in a city where all these things
are happening all these things are
happening it's a very Vibrant Community
I guess what I was what I was uh moving
towards was that you be you part you
love to participate you love to know
what's going on so you do watch some
things that maybe your typical person
might think verer Herzog doesn't view
you watched the
Kardashians um very very few but I do
watch uh I do watch some trash TV uh
like let's say
WrestleMania hell yeah and someone is
like hurts up enough about Madness let's
talk about wrestling no it's no but it's
it's very interesting because it's a
very crude form of of drama has emerged
and it's it's a dramas that are not in
the fight itself the fights are
interrupted by commercials meaning
they're not that important but the owner
of the franchise shows up in the in the
uh ring uh his wife alleged wife in a
wheelchair and blind and he has
three three sexy women in his arm and
and rants against his wife in the
wheelchair and all of a sudden you have
a form of of uh drama going on a new
form emerging apparently probably as
crude as ancient Greek drama uh started
out in the fifth century before Christ
so I I watch it for number one I think
the the poet must not close his eyes
avert his eyes you have to know in which
world you are living know yes yeah and
and I uh and I have nothing against
uh uh let's say once in a while it's
isn't on the air anymore Here Comes
Honey Boo
Boo yeah that's my favorite the way you
said it yeah is going to be a that'll be
a meme where that's no but but uh but
very very fascinating yeah there's
something something deep about uh about
Society in it deep about something deep
about the American Dre dream that goes
Ary
somehow um and I I can see how the
American dream is function functioning
because I've been uh in the heartland of
America I have worked in Wisconsin I
worked in Louisiana I have worked in uh
North
Carolina uh I've lived in Pittsburgh
with a guest family who who picked me up
from the street when I was
homeless without hesitation I was part
of the best that America can can give
you and um so uh I think I think much of
the political Chasm between left and
right is due to the neglect of the of uh
the center the heartland of
America uh people say ah are the the
flyovers but they live in Boston or in
Seattle or in Los Angeles in yeah in New
York and I ask have you ever been in
Wisconsin no but I have worked there so
and and I find it I find it an outrage
that the some of the best of America
very good people living there of course
under represented in the media um with
much less accent access to
education uh underpaid uh without that
open access to um to the American dream
and and this is why you have such
conflicts now yes I agree 100% with what
you just said I think there's a
condescension there's a condescension
among the
elit there's a condescension wonderful
people and I am very much uh very much
in favor of uh looking at them and I
don't know where did you grow up as a I
grew up right outside Boston so outside
of Boston but many people who uh are
here in the film industry grew up in
Kansas or in in in Minnesota or in
wherever Arkansas I say why why don't
you contact your old school buddies uh
tell them what they are doing and and be
interested in what they are doing
are what are they thinking what are they
doing put them on your on your radar let
them know they are around there and you
like them and you like Arkansas and you
like
Wisconsin and do they do it no
unfortunately too very few now I I
cannot give you statistics but uh much
of what I'm saying now is disappointing
yeah Los Angeles is not a disappointment
I I lived in uh San Francisco for a few
years and I I said now I have to move
and I talked to my wife we have to move
to the city with the most substance and
it was immediately clear Los
Angeles